but if you remember the beginning of the
afghan war we were just sweeping people
up some of them terrorists some of them
not
and sending them to places like
guantanamo bay sending them to bagram
which i believe is in afghanistan it
might have been in iraq sending them the
places to i think it was in afghanistan
bagram air force base uh it's
afghanistan yes sending them to places
like the salt pit to be tortured look
that up look up the salt
the bagram salt
yeah
the salt plate was a black prison
okay meaning that it was a cia black
site for interrogation it's located
north of kabul and was the location of a
brick factory prior to the afghanistan
war that's where we would bring people
and torture them
because we were there to help them
you see
we were there to help them and we would
bring them to this uh underground prison
this brick factory here and torture them
mercilessly
until they gave us some type of
information um and people were tortured
to death and died there and how do you
think that made the people in
afghanistan feel do you think we lost a
few hearts and minds with that with the
salt pit
do you think perhaps yeah ex u.s
detainees describe unreported c.i.a
torture
you know i mean it's like jesus electric
chair threats guys yeah water torture
waterboarding beatings
threatened with electric chair they
would put people in boxes and put bugs
in there let them crawl on them i mean
this was again
this was how we were going to break the
spirit of these people well guess what
it didn't work
didn't work we lost this one and we lost
and there's there's no other way to yes
we could drop a bombs and nukes or
whatever but we lost the ground game
here big time we didn't have the will
nor should we have the will we're
fighting for afghanistan
um
and this sucks
it sucks across the board it sucks for
the afghans that thought they were gonna
have a different life it sucks for the
soldiers who died and their deaths
don't don't mean anything it sucks for
the people that went over there to do
some charity
that sucks
if you're still there it's you know it
really is gonna test
how much
you believe i mean you know
show
the afghan airport show that plane
leaving okay
this is a very
this is a crazy
scene to watch you see this c17
this is a wild video to watch if you
haven't seen it which i'm sure you have
and i'm telling you right now
uh
there's a few days here before as i said
on the patreon we're gonna get a media
blackout and once there's a media
blackout it's pretty much
you know
we're pretty much done
no one's gonna care anymore so now that
look at this
okay ben this is the wrong video this is
the scene of austin texas this is a
scene
of people leaving austin texas look at
this
they're all leaving
look at this scene of people running
down south congress to get out of austin
texas to go back to a real city
that's the austin airport
there's all the comics that moved here
they thought they were gonna be on joe
rogan's show every week
they're gonna comics are gonna leave
austin like afghani translators that
worked with the department of defense
they are going to get on planes so
quickly and get the [ __ ] out of there
because they all thought they were
coming down here to do rogan show
you know
and then he had some guy that he like
you know
hunted for bigfoot with on the ninth for
the ninth time
and all these comics are sitting here in
austin going wait a minute when's my
time
you better cling to that plane